you
hi everyone is Jerry recently chess
legend and many times over world chess
champion Garry Kasparov I guess we could
say came out of retirement for just a
very brief window of time on November
28th 2014 he played a two game chess
exhibition match against UC Haruka boo
those who are not familiar with the boo
he is widely considered one of the
greatest shogi players having recently
won his 1300 the professional shogi
match he is only one of four players
ever to reach that feat and the youngest
ever at the age of 44 to do so
additionally he is a feat a chess master
having a rating of just over 2,400 and
is the number one ranked chess player in
Japan these two games were played in an
effort to promote a series of shogi
games between professional players and
computers that will take place in March
of 2015 so if you're interested in shogi
I guess be on the lookout for that
these two games had rapid time controls
that I'm going to review here briefly
rapid time controls with 25 minutes each
and a 10-second increment in this first
game Kasparov he had the white pieces
opening with Knight f3 uh boo replying
with tonight f6 on the white end
Kasparov goes forward with a King's
Indian set up looking for a Kings Indian
attack essentially getting in this
efore push and after black castles in a
5 basically the battle lines have
already been drawn white is looking to
go straight after the black King with
these typical maneuvers rookie one
Knight f1 h4 and the knight rerouting to
this g4 square one thing to note here is
that instead of castles if white is
excuse me if black is capturing on e4
notice how there is the immediate
recapture without fear of dropping e4 if
Knight takes e4 there would follow the
strong reply 95 and black is a Navy
very difficult position you may think
that the knight can simply move out of
the way and defend the bishop and while
that's true notice how both the night
and this pawn here on f7 would be
unprotected Queen f3 and this is
basically game over so the short story
here is that it's not wise to take twice
on this e4 square so black simply gets
on with more development castling ePHI
vis in 97 rook e1 dual-purpose defend
the pawn make way for this Knight
maneuver c5 Knight f1 knight c6 some
natural stuff here comes h4 there's an
additional meaning behind this as well
it's not just there to vacate h2 but
also looks to plant up here to h5 and
looking to induce some further
weaknesses with h6 weakening these dark
squares the f6 square in particular can
certainly turn out to be quite sensitive
following up we have Knight to d4 and
this is already a slight misstep maybe
you might regard it as a big misstep as
black is now going to lose a pond
instead of 90 for a better attempt is to
expand further on the Queen side with b5
in a way it's maybe I guess we could say
losing a tempo I think black can achieve
a similar position and still have this
pawn get to the b5 square in one stroke
but this would have been I guess a
better attempt at this stage but after
Knight d4 this is now going to be big
trouble for black after Knight takes
Knight pawn takes we don't really get
into this situation where the knight is
coming in to g4
instead it's queen g4 immediately
hitting at two things the unprotected d4
pawn and well with this pawn being
pinned there's this idea of Bishop to h6
and this is the more pressing issue
right here this is the more serious
threat for the bishop to get into h6 and
so the end result is that black is now
going to drop this pawn
without much compensation at all I in
fact I don't think that there is
compensation trying to defend like this
again Bishop h6 and you have to give up
the exchange so lac is having to give up
the pawn rook e8 Queen takes D and white
is just looking for some simplification
c3 is good enough f6 takes takes Queen
gets back over to an aggressive post on
G 495 and now simply Bishop to f4 it's a
very difficult road ahead we're going to
have now the Queen's being exchanged
white basically needing to consolidate
there's no compensation here white gets
rocked back just a little bit pawn takes
pawn takes this pawn is now a bit
sensitive White has a simple idea of
just piling up on that guy rook to d8
rookie - here we go with the battery
against e4 not really good way to defend
Bishop e5 Knight e3 a couple more minor
pieces come off the rooks are doubled
another pawn is going to fall a black
rook now gets very active but it's not
really going to be enough with white now
being up a full pawn and on top of this
we're now seeing a very active Knight
this guy on g4 g5 and the rook on e4
coordinate very well against this black
King in fact there's already this mate
threat on ee8 and even ideas to win the
bishop this is after all loose piece on
c7 so black is very limited playing
Bishop d6 who gives a check the bishop
now has to get into a pin and our rook
to b8 initially I was thinking to pile
up on the pinned piece but the king
could sneak out with King f7 so instead
it's rook to b8 now this is a serious
threat Black has to defend that Square
and does so with rookie to King f1
rookie 7
white is now up still a second pun and
is now quick to get right back to pin
this bishop after King g7 getting out of
the pin after c4 it's at this point that
Hibou resigns there's not a good way to
prevent the very simple marching of this
past paunch promotion the king has to
stay here to defend the bishop the
bishop can't move at all and the rook
can't go too far either because of this
knight check this is the only safe
Square but it could be kicked away with
that for if rookie three there's King F
2 if bishop here you could attack the
bishop this is very big trouble for team
black bishop d4 d5 there's just not
going to be a good way out of this from
this position Bishop b6 you can play C 5
you're going to be winning a piece and
if black doesn't want to win a piece
there's just nothing type of moves that
could be played here just passing along
here the pawn just marches again as soon
as it gets this point it would be
indirectly defended due to a fork but
again in this game 1 it was after this
c4 move that Babu resigned so let's have
a look at this second game that first
one here that I just showed was kind of
over after just a dozen moves it's going
back here as soon as that night to d4
move was played right here is real big
trouble right here in fact yes after
this night to d4 move that was the big
mistake in this game this second game
however this was a much more closely
fought game for sure with now the colors
reversed
abbu having the white side he opens with
e4 have them I guess you could say that
the modern defense here on the black
side going with the King side fianchetto
we have an interesting ID on the black
side too well not be so quick to castle
for one because of these ideas of
exchanging dark square Bishop sand
launching this age pawn up white is very
quick to queenside castle and play on
the H file if black is to do so or if
black is to allow the dark square bishop
exchange so in other words this Knight
will not be
quick to develop at least not without
having let's say this pond first on h6
we do see that take shape in fact after
h4 here black plays h6 Kasparov plays h6
here preparing to meet h5 with g5 white
castle's the b-59 h3 Knight f6 and now
f3 keeping that night out of the g4
square trying to preserve that dark
square Bishop Knight b6 Knight f4 and
now after b4 there's a misstep here on
the white side the move played was night
e2 and this is allowing this dark square
bishop to be picked right up a better
move is Knight to be for just staying
out of the way of this light square
bishop so you can keep a close eye on c4
but instead it was nighty to black is
now able to pick up that Bishop and will
now look to play on the dark squares
first it's with c6 watching out for that
d5 square and clearing the diagonal for
the Queen King be one Queen b6 this
Queen after all is unprotected and what
comes to mind are ideas like e5 to break
down these dark squares white gets out
of that with Queen d2 H 5 H 5 is
interesting if you're going with a quick
Castle you could come under some heavy
fire after g4 g 5 and this h-file be
quick to be peeled open notice the Queen
from d2 should the H file be opened up
she would be quick to make use of the h2
square and form a battery looking to
attack that black King so its first h5
making some type of pawn break certainly
making white's h5 advance more difficult
to get in having a lot of big grip over
the g4 square essentially with this last
move h5 falling up we have E 5 kickin
that night away he goes back to well he
doesn't go back anywhere in fact I was
thinking here there'd be something
seriously wrong with Knight to d7 I
should be pointing this out
night Knight to d7 is met with this
crushing east six move
forget about your King side structure
this is getting destroyed broken right
down g6 is weak this Knight is hit black
is still on Castle this would be a very
poor choice so instead it's Knight d5
gives up a pawn but notice how we're
quick to maybe have well not quick to
have anything but we're going to have a
situation where the Kings are Castle
down opposite wings so having material
plus is not necessarily such a big
factor in the game we had ripped to a
seven another move that could have been
played as simply castles without fear of
Queen takes rook because of Bishop to b7
we could have this imbalance and at the
end black can be very disruptive to the
coordination of the white pieces if
white is trying something like f4 to
negate this Bishop there can follow
Bishop h6 and if let's say rook h3
trying to get some coordination in this
manner Queen the f2 is a very strong
move putting a ton of pressure on
basically every white piece it's not so
easy to coordinate should white give up
the Queen and get the two rooks in
return so what follows is rook a seven
we didn't have Castle it was certainly a
fine option but instead it was rook a
seven Queen d4 offering a queen exchange
and white is after all up upon black
avoids lap Knight f4 and we have this
exchange I guess white at this stage was
content with giving the pawn back in
order to get the dark square bishop
that's the main imbalance in this
position aside from material it's
related to black having the bishop hair
versus these two guys Knight f4 the
alternative is to simply preserve that
pond with that four but this also allows
this bishop to get right in here and
there's still a lot of pressure that
black can be placing on the white side
so sensing that type of pressure
why to invest some material back giving
the eponymous the bishop with this
series of exchanges here and now we have
a pretty much debt equal position very
active rook here and well I shouldn't
even say debt equal I would probably
prefer to play the white side here
having the more active rook black still
needing to get castled here and well as
we see with these next two moves rook d5
okay seven notice the more actively
placed rook at this stage so after this
check King f8 this isn't much of an
inconvenience to the black side that can
you'll be quite alright on g7y doubles
King g7 we have a little bit of a back
and forth here Kasparov is not so quick
to exchange bishops but I guess cannot
avoid it wants to go for some more so he
tries something else we have the bishops
come off now and it's a rook ending
alone who stands the better side this
now starts to tip ever so slightly in
blacks favor due to I believe the King
position as we'll soon see
black first put some pressure on see two
lights there to defend white can't be so
our white isn't so inconvenienced by
having to defend this c2 pawn but if we
do a capice comparison a king comparison
again it's blacks King who's a little
bit better he starts to get active with
King f6 King to e5 whereas this King
going exactly he's taking a hike right
towards this square here where he puts
pressure on both g2 and h4 rook H our
rook to a6 the rook is there to defend
we have one pair of rooks come off and
now this is just not going to be working
out for the white side it's not fast
enough this pawn is going to be enough
of an annoyance is going to allow black
just enough time to get his own pass
pawn created and again this very active
King versus a not so active King is the
big factor and this more simplified
ending this more technical ending with
the
just being one pair rook on each side
just having one rook here much more
technical after a three king f4 takes
takes rook d4 so after this capture
White has two connected passed pawns but
this guy here is super fast at this
stage I was thinking King takes g2 and
that's fine but I really like the
technique here on the black side instead
going with E five this King doesn't want
to grab the pawn instead he wants to
simply play rook e7 and push this pawn
away and there's not a good way to stop
that even if this King comes over here
to try and guard these three squares
he 1 e2 e3 the black King would be there
to simply offset the white King black is
simply too fast at this stage white
offers a rook exchange that's avoided
the rook essentially getting past or
getting behind what is soon to be a past
epon b4e 4 takes takes b5 e 3 and that's
all she wrote that's it white ends up
resigning here he's just going to be way
too fast and this is a completely one
position for team black but a much more
testing attempt here by Hibou in this
game - I'd be curious to see what takes
place if these guys were to play a shogi
match I would I do not know how to play
shogi feel free to let me know in the
comments section if you play the game if
these two do play shogi I will try to
make it a point to learn shogi and
present those two games well until that
time comes as always I hope you enjoyed
this video and maybe found it a little
bit fun take care bye
you
you